here's what some celebrities pay for
monthly child support payments Kanye
pays Kim two hundred thousand dollars a
month for their four children Robert
Kardashian initially paid twenty
thousand dollars a month for his
daughter with Blac Chyna but he now pays
nothing Britney Spears used to pay Kevin
Federline twenty thousand dollar a month
for their two sons but allegedly in 2018
that was up to thirty five thousand
Kelly Clarkson pays forty five thousand
dollars a month in child support for her
two children
Jesse Williams used to pay forty
thousand dollars a month in child
support for his two children but
apparently in 2022 that amount was
lowered to six thousand four hundred and
thirteen dollars which is quite a dip
Tom Cruise pays Katie Holmes 33 000 a
month in child support for their
daughter Holly Berry pays sixteen
thousand dollars a month in child
support for her daughter 50 Cent paid
six thousand and seven hundred dollars a
month in child support for his son until
he turned 18. and Charlie Sheen had to
pay fifty five thousand dollars a month
to Brook Mueller and twenty thousand
dollars a month to Denise Richards but
in 2021 it was reported that his payment
to Denise Richards went down to zero
dollars